ça va tout de suite faire un point avec
vous thomas bonnet sur les chiffres
qu'il faut retenir
à cette heure avec une poussée des verts
ce soir poussée des verts dans plusieurs
villes de france plusieurs grandes
villes de france honda parle d'abord de
lyon où c'était loin d'être acquis
pourtant et bien grégory doucet serait
en tête selon les premières estimations
une forte large avance selon ces mêmes
estimations pour le candidat d'europe
écologie les verts qui devance yann
cucherat percée également des
écologistes à bordeaux où c'est pour
l'occurrence pierre hurmic qui serait en
tête devant nicolas florian nicolas
florian qui on le rappelle est le
successeur d'alain juppé à la mairie de
bordeaux au premier tour seule une
petite centaine de voix séparaient les
deux hommes nicolas florian le candidat
les républicains qui avaient pu compter
sur le ralliement du candidat de la
république en marche bien cela n'a
semble-t-il pas suffi puisque selon ses
estimations c'est donc pierre hurmic qui
est en tête coude à coude également à
lille où martine aubry n'est pas encore
assuré d'être réélu à la tête de la
mairie puisque là encore c'est un
candidat d'europe écologie les verts qui
lui dispute la victoire stéphane baly
l'écart est très très serré ça va se
jouer à quelques suffrages on attend la
fin définitive
enfin complète du dépouillement dans la
ville de lille résultats également à
strasbourg où c'est là encore la
candidate écologiste des écologistes
jeanne mars evian qui arrive en tête
devant le candidat de la république en
marche puis à marseille c'est michel
ruby rôle à la candidate qui a réalisé
une alliance de la gauche qui serait là
aussi en tête avec une large avance
selon les premières estimations points
quand même pour de satisfaction pour la
république en marche c'est à toulouse où
le candidat jean luc moudenc qui a
soutenu à la fois par les républicains
et par la république en marche résistera
est là aussi la à la percée du candidat
d'europe écologie les verts antoine
maurice puisque jean luc moudenc serait
en tête
selon les premières estimations les
verts transforme l'essai donc merci
thomas